اكدت واشنطن ان القمه الامريكيه اليابانيه
الكوريه الجنوبيه في منتجع ليست مواجهه ضد
اي ضد اي دوله وان هدفها تعزيز الاستقرار
والامن الاقليميين كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات من رسائل التي
تريد قمه بالتوجيهها ما الحسابات التي
تحكم علاقه واشنطن وحلفائها في منطقه
المحيطين الهادئ والهندي ببيجيم عن
المسارات التي يمكن ان ياخذها الاستقرار
في منطقه المحيطين الهادئ والهندي
عنوان لهذه القمه قد نسميها قمه النيتو
الاسيوي انه ايذاء تاتشين لتحالف ثلاثي
دفاعي لاول مره بين ثلاثه دول هي امريكا
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
هذه القمه قمه تاريخيه وهي لانها كذلك
تقول الولايات المتحده
اذا ما نجحت فهي الشركه الرئيسي في هذا
لتحقيق هذه المظلمه الثقه التي يمكن ان
تولي ان يولد بها اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
خلافاتهم جانبا ليشتمعا على مبدا الثقه
بالقطع هدف الرئيسي اولا هو واحتواء الصين
الامر الثاني هو ردع كوريا الشماليه الامر
الثالث بمواجهه مقاديبدو تحالفا ثلاثيا
مقابلا لذلك هو التحالف الصيني الروسي مع
كوريا الشماليه
رساله خاطئه وخطيره اعتقد ان الشعوب شرق
اسيا عليها ان تستمر في دعم السلام
والاستقرار بدلا من ان تقع في هذا الفخذ
الصراع والتسابق التسليح
[موسيقى]
بتكلم على وضع جديد تكون فيه امريكا بشكل
او باخر باحتواء الصين من خلال من خلال
القيام بتحالفات اقليميه الصين تدعم روسيا
في هجومها على اوكرانيا وسياده اوكرانيا
وهذا امر ادانته لامم الجمعيه العامل
المتحده وتصير قد كشفت ومنافقه فتتحدث عن
حمايه سياده الاراضي والدول لكن عندما فقط
عندما يتعلق الصين لا تدعم طرفا على الاخر
في الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا الصين حتى
الطرفين على ايقاف الحرب واستخدام الطرق
الدبلوماسيه والمفاوضات من اجل حل اي
مشكله لديهما
وهذا يعتبر في الراي الشخصي تحول نوعي في
التوازنات الاستراتيجيه من العالم خاصه في
ظل وجود توترات صينيه امريكيه سواء جزء
منها متعلق بتايوان وجود قوات عسكريه
امريكيه ناريها على الاقل 80 الف جندي في
تلك المنتخب من العالم
حقيقه تصعد وتزيد التوتر وتريد ان تستخدم
الوسائل العسكريه من اجل ان تقدم
لرساله تدعو الى الصراع والحرب فيما يتعلق
بالوضع في شرق الموقف العدواني الصيني فيه
هو الذي يؤدي الى الدعم الدول تبحث عن
تحالفات الصين وروسيا يدعمان كوريا
الشماليه وهي اكثر دوله غير مسؤوله وخطيره
لديها اسلحه نوويه ماذا سيحدث لو
قامت دول اخرى لهذا التحالف مثلا اذا قررت
امريكا في وقت من الاوقات ضم تايوان هذا
التحالف ماذا يعني هذا ضم الهند قد تنضم
اليه ماليزيا واندونيسيا وبالتالي بنتكلم
على اعاده المطلق عليه الهيكل الامني في
منطقه جنوب شرق اسيا وشرق اسيا الجنوبي
اعتقد ان الشيء الوحيد الذي ستقوم به
الصين هو دعوه كل الاطراف من ان تسعى نحو
السلم بدلا من تشجيع الحرب والجيش
الامريكي عليها ان لا ينسى الدرس الذي
يتلقاه بعد هزيمته في حرب الكوريه
[موسيقى]